we have this from the post-millennial
special counsel David Weiss expected to
deliver Hunter Biden indictment by
September 29th Weiss said Hunter Biden
faces firearm related charges as well as
two counts of tax fraud now I wonder
about these stories because of course we
want accountability for corrupt
individuals we know that Joe Biden was
involved this could be a first step that
leads to an impeachment of Joe Biden but
I kind of feel like they are going to
find a way to give this dude a slap on
the wrist right so you got a couple
stories one right now you got January
6ers being given these harsh penalties
years in prison decades in prison
Enrique tario wasn't even there and then
you get stories like this Denver to pay
$4.7 million to settle claims that
targeted George Floyd protesters so it's
absolutely fascinating insane yeah the
the left goes out in riots across the
country 30 plus dead and multiple
jurisdictions are paying them I think
the total so far was like $100 million
so we may be seeing the charges of
Hunter Biden but as you were just
mentioning yeah where's Kevin marthy
where are the Republicans where is he
aty they never they never do anything
it's it is the most frustrating part of
it right when you when you pay that
close attention and you're wondering why
is it that it seems like they're
constantly like Democrats the left they
they make territory they get good
territory all the time they're always
able to do that but for some reason the
Republicans never do it because the
Republicans are just Democrats going the
speed limit if not slower because they
don't actually want to make any changes
and the the Republican Party is divided
if you if you look at the Democrats even
listen some of them probably don't like
Joe Biden but they but you will never
know they're not going to speak out
against Joe they're all going to they're
all going to be on they're all going to
act like they're on the same page you
know Joe Biden's a good president now
here you got the Republicans divided you
got this you got you got half of them
attacking Trump half of them saying
let's let's uh let's uh stand behind
Trump when we need all of them to be
standing behind and even when Trump was
even even when Trump was the president
the Republican party was divided you
know yep was there was there numbers on
the amount I think we covered this at
some point right there there was numbers
on the amount of people that said if
they had known about the hunter Biden
laptop Scandal before the election it's
like 7 to 8% 7 to 8% like I was talking
to some recently they don't even think
that they they think that the
Republicans or them going after Hunter
Biden's a losing plan anyways like they
they don't feel like it actually moves
the needle enough enough to make it
worth it other than if you're actually
acting on principle and doing it because
you actually want to prosecute somebody
that's committing a crime I don't
completely disagree I think that going
after Hunter Biden is not necessarily an
election issue it's an accountability
issue but it does lead to the business
dealings of Joe Biden who is now it's
being reported using what Alias is to
communicate with Hunter to give him
prived information because he was using
Hunter as a proxy to conduct a business
while as VP and this is this is this is
part of the news that's coming out which
could be the hunter Biden indictments
could be the leadup to the impeachment
of Joe Biden it'll give them more
Authority we'll see what happens I I I I
I really don't want to give the
Republicans the benefit of the doubt I
don't believe they'll do things part of
me says maybe they're going to slow roll
it until the election year you'd rather
have an October surprise than a year
early October announcement that's not a
surprise for anybody you give them a
year in advance to deal with and that's
an attorney aternity in an election you
want to come out with the damaging
information right as early voting starts
then people don't vote and have an
impact so maybe that's when they try and
do it I don't know will it even matter
anyways cuz the media will just suppress
it but but the but we are the media
right and so looking looking at CNN's
ratings in the trash can and now Fox
news's ratings are in the trash can it's
actually going to be the likes of uh Joe
Rogan Russell Brand Patrick Bet David
timcast IRL Jimmy door more and more
people are consuming information through
these platforms which is exactly why for
instance budlight sees a massive
derailing of their of their stock value
look our our our the younger generation
grew up consuming media in this way I
don't think any show ever reaches the
level of Tucker Carlson back you know uh
10 20 years ago you had very few
channels so everybody watched very
similar things there's there's there's
pros and there's cons to that the
benefit is that most people uh or I
should say there there is a benefit in
people being on the same page in terms
of facts if the facts being given cor
given out are correct but then you end
up with mil intelligence agency
influence and lies and then everyone
believes lies the internet allows people
to challenge the machine fact check
prove it provide evidence check sources
now the there there's a net negative in
that sense that you know like a show
like this like Tucker Carlson was
getting three to five million every
night I don't think anyone ever gets
that big ever again right we get like a
tenth of that and and to be fair the
majority of those those viewers are
older because they were used to watching
this these these older networks but now
that you have a diversified group of
citizens getting you know different like
this the correct information but from
different perspectives like all the
podcasts I mentioned it's hard to break
that it's hard to lie to a group of
people that have all these different
sources because you can't Mockingbird
this it's easy when you got four four
networks and the CIA or the FBI or
whatever they say look for national
security reasons don't report this story
and they all agree when it came to the
NSA files the um this was the Snowden
stuff you have uh oh no no let's I I
think the the uh there's a bunch of
different whistleblower examples and you
have um what movie was it I think Julian
Assange one these news outlets are like
what do we do with these releases we
have to be careful let's ask the US
government about it that don't matter
anymore because now if intelligence
agencies want to try and pull a Mocking
Bird good luck reaching out to 10,000
podcasts you can't do what they'll do
the next generation of Mockingbird is
they'll deep fake someone that's
respected like Patrick B David they'll
deep fake him saying something that
isn't true so it's like a reverse
Mocking Bird instead of trying to give
you the false information they're going
to trick you into believing it they'll
try and then it'll also defame they
can't do that bet David they can try and
defame someone like you know any one of
these podcast hosts but Patrick P
David's audience trusts him they know
him he'll come out and say that's not
true guys and people are going to
believe him they could try to create a
fake Channel where they come out with a
with a pro like a prop personality but
they're not going to get enough reach
what they could do is they can go to the
parent platform let's say there's a
large social network called like your
your your TV oh your TV okay your TV and
on your TV they create rules that defy
logic that go against doctors uh and
medical science but adhere to political
instructions and then they ban anyone
who goes against it that's the best they
can do the only problem is the market
will solve for this then you're going to
end up with I don't know there'll be
some alternative called like fumble or
something that will actually shout out
to rumble Rumble emerges and then
outright says not only are you allowed
your Free Speech but we will create an
ad Network to support you and they're
getting there here's I'll give you guys
some interesting information we the live
show is here on YouTube but we put all
our clips and everything on Rumble as if
it's any other platform and we get on my
morning show I get like 30,000 views on
average I get about 180 to 200 depending
on the video on YouTube and I'm getting
about 30,000 on Rumble timcast IRL Clips
actually are rivaled on Rumble this is
the fascinating thing we might put up a
clip on YouTube from this show that gets
200,000 every so often we'll have a big
clip like that and then periodically
we'll get 50 to maybe 90 on Rumble we
get 50 to 100,000 views on these clips
Rumble Rumble is stripping away market
value from YouTube and YouTube too
stupid to realize it yeah they are yeah
so I have a new podcast it's called the
Terence K Williams podcast um it took me
a long time to come up with that
name but now this is embarrassing but
the podcast is new and my the average V
the average the the average episode gets
5,000 views on YouTube I posted one EP I
posted an episode with me and Dean Kane
on Rumble it got a 100,000 views
I'm like what in the world Superman
first Rumble rumble's audience are many
of the refugees from these platforms so
you will find people who are more into
politics you're going to have a that
that's there's going to be a huge market
share a huge Advantage there but with
Rumble getting into sports yo I was
watching a skate video skateboarding
listen to this because most you probably
I don't care about skateboarding no no
no pro skateboarders and the private
skate park to all of their 16 17y old
viewers Rumble Sports on the wall and
I'm like that's it Rumble Sports sounds
good yep main Rumble Sports mainstream
branding in mainstream pop culture that
kids are going to watch and when they go
to rumble to watch their Sports and
video games they got Terence Williams
right there yep you know what Trump does
need to do though if he's if we're
talking mainstream he needs to just like
whine and dine the ladies from the view
cuz he he really does struggle with you
know if we're talking like Suburban
women he's not the most liked person he
needs to just whine and dine the ladies
from the view and really get them to
turn around he's been on The View do you
think he could you remember when he was
on The View and he was asked to run for
president oh yeah I think rosan asked
they used toan and Trump in the I mean
there was stuff going back to the '90s
of of Oprah asking him when he was going
to run for president but I have to fact
check you the women on The View those
ladies they are not Suburban women those
are dumb women yeah but they speak they
speak to Suburban women their Their
audience is Suburban women at home oh
the other day when Joy bear was like
it's back I was like so cringe cringe
yeah but whoopy won't be here like they
27 they're in their 27th season which is
insane but why are they not adhering to
the writers and actor strike out but are
people really they don't even know what
they're talking about are women are
people really watching The View yes they
they affect they yes I do I absolutely
believe that they affect the Suburban
female voting demographics big time
because they're not they're not like the
the stats say that men watch you YouTube
more than women right if I remember
correctly so if a woman is watching
terrestrial television she's going to be
watching something she's cleaning during
the day she's she's getting her kids uh
lunches ready she's watching The View
and she's seeing a bunch of spewed you
know deep State propaganda being you
know fed back to her and that's the
voting block that's going to end up
costing you election if you can't swing
at least some of the female demographic
I don't think that there's much their
ratings are way down way way way way
down but they're still getting between
like 1 8 to2 million view viewers but it
just it it Cycles through so one so one
lady watches it and she goes to her
knitting group of of women and they talk
about what she talked about in the
episode that day and it permeates more
naturally right it's not that they all
watch it they also when you see that
stuff you don't talk about like they get
clips clips get posted on social media
there's more than just the live numbers
that affect how how far someone's
reaches on a lot of these platforms so
yeah I I just don't think there's
nothing that Trump can do to satisfy
not at all there's nothing and and if
Trump went on their show the whole show
would be a gotta show but you need to
consider too yeah it's not even
necessarily about Trump convincing them
to vote for him it's about the
Republicans in general convincing
Democrats not to support Joe Biden right
so and it's funny because the Democrats
are going to be like oh Tim P saying
people should not vote I'm like no I'm
saying vote for somebody else yeah vote
like Joe Biden's not going to give you
anything he's just going to keep doing
garbled nonsense War in Europe you want
World War II vote for Joe Biden you want
a crippled economy vote for Joe Biden
I'm not even I won't even say this I'm
not going to tell you right now to vote
for Trump I'm say don't vote for Biden
you know if you want social justice then
you vote for uh Cornell West right he's
your he's your leftist Progressive guy
you want uh The Establishment to get a
stake through its vampiric heart you
vote for Donald Trump and that's not
even a guarantee it actually happens but
it's the best shot you've got do you
think VI is Just Too Young Too new to
actually have a chance at winning the
presidency yes it's it's winning the
presidency is more than just being like
playing the game properly the the
reality to VI is that it's he he would
need to to
make every perfect step which he is
doing with very few mistakes uh he would
need to make every move perfectly and
hit every die roll perfectly yeah he
would need the Deep state to prop him up
that's what Obama had that's why he went
from obscurity to fame so fast that
would help I'm not saying that I'm
saying there are certain things you can
do in your campaign that you can do
right or wrong he needs to roll like
three 20s in a row yes that's tough
because no money on that Trump trump has
the base Trump has a great track record
with the economy and with a lot of a lot
of issues that he's so famous well he's
he's super famous but but you look at
foreign policy Abraham Accords you look
at uh the attempts at peace deals
outside of that you look at uh timeline
for withdraw from Afghanistan which Joe
Biden screwed up but I mostly for
Americans gas prices were low the
economy was great then Co hit it's hard
to blame him just for that because under
Biden you also had Co the co went from
Trump and through Biden so they both get
hit on that point Trump could have done
things a lot better but Trump's got a
track record people like like you were
saying you want to see Trump keep doing
these things you know he getting rid of
the TPP one of the first things he did
bolstering US manufacturing bringing
autom manufacturing back to the Rust
Belt the attempts to secure our border
far from perfect but heavy efforts being
made people like these things the the
the best numbers of Our Lives Jim Kramer
said that Jim Kramer was always wrong
was celebrating how great the economy
was so on that alone I think Donald
Trump is beating out vi vi has to get
lucky and there's a lot that would have
to happen for him to actually win so you
can be the best guy for the job and I
think V in many ways is but because of
the problems we we face in terms of
corruption
v may not be he may not be the right
person like he speaks he speaks well he
he plays politics very well he's got
great policy ideas he fleshes them out
he addresses a lot of issues we want to
see
addressed but there's there's that fire
that I don't know that he actually has
that Trump does have because Trump was
personally slighted you know what I mean
yeah I don't see people rallying behind
vake it's harder yeah and his name is
kind of hard to pronounce too in the
beginning I was it's gets his name wrong
a challenge for him that's not
presidential it's just not change should
change his name like raw lightning now
what do you think
of so what do y'all think about Ronda
santz if if Trump is not the nominee you
think he can beat Joe Biden uh yes he
could beat Joe Biden I think the be you
think he has a better chance in beating
Joe Biden no than who than Trump than
president Trump not if it was on the
board but I feel like there's so much
back behind the scenes crap against
Trump that it's like and this one really
bums me out because a year ago I've said
hands down no question but then we got
to watch how Des santis ran his campaign
and now I'm just like no he he I think
Des sis would could beat Biden because
he's he's less unlikable yeah right he's
just kind of there yeah but Biden is
unlikable his age is a problem you've
got a quarter of Democrats saying that
they can't vote for him he's too old and
then you get Ronda sanis who would just
be there and I think that should be
enough he he would effectively be Biden
to Biden right Joe Biden was the
corporeal form Democrats asked for
nobody really wanted to vote for Biden
they just wanted to vote against Trump
well you're going to get a lot of people
who would support Des santis a lot of
people begrudgingly would support des
sandis and then a lot of people would
just blindly be is better than Biden
yeah Donald Trump however would rally
people he would so I I I I think I think
Dan santis could have been it if if
DeSantis ran the campaign that V is
running he would be ahead of vake right
now do you think that because I saw
Chuck Todd interview VI I think VI's
been on he's been on some of like the
leftist mass media Legacy Media stuff is
it because they're attempting to split
the party in half for the voters so that
the Democrats
win say that one more time why would
they would prop Viv a up and just go
like Chuck Todds really seems to like
him and want him on his show and
interview him like are they just trying
to create a division in the Republican
party there gonna be a nominee I mean
Ronda Sanz is already doing that right
so they so they don't need to use uh V
for see his name I can't even pronounce
his damn name but but yeah the is more
is more likely I told this to him I was
like I don't think you're going to win
and I think you know you're not going to
win right like no no one as smart as
that guy joins this race being like I
can beat Trump no you can't you cannot
defeat Donald Trump in this primary so
VI is playing it masterfully he's
supporting Trump while running against
him it's brilliant I would love to see
him in Trump's
cabinet love to see him in his cabinet
he said he didn't want to be vice
president though right he did he told me
that yeah but he has to say that so
we'll see he has to say that cuz he's
running for a president but hey yeah he
just C Trump ramas Swami would be a
powerful ticket because really would be
because VI is playing the game perfectly
but he's not in a presidential position
and he's the guy that you don't want if
I'm speaking from the deep States
perspective who's like afraid they're
going to lose their jobs you don't want
VI to become the president because he'll
fire you he will terminate your job so
those people are like yo we don't if
he's the VP you will make sure that
President stays in power because you do
not VI stepping in ending a bunch of the
corruption you're all corrup I'm just
imagining it and I just know it's never
going to play like this but you know
they Trump gets elected V is the VP and
that and you know they walk into the
Oval Office they sit down Trump looks up
and he goes do it and then v stands up
buttons his jacket walks out of the hall
and then makes the phone call and then
they're all fired that's the thing if VI
did serve as vice president I think it
could be a lot more of a a front-facing
public role than Pence did Pence was
like behind the scenes quiet Meek yeah
exactly Vic's a loud guy like he's he
loves to talk in front of crowds and
stuff and he can rally the people he can
explain complicated things technically
to the American people
he would he would serve as an excellent
translator for Trump's weird like
Trump's like build a wall and was like
why he didn't explain the Chinese are
running our fentanyl through the
southern border I thought it was a
xenophobic move at first I thought he
hated the central Americans I thought he
was like we don't want those people here
it was a drug it's a drug cartels
running human trafficking if if that had
been the message early on I don't think
he would have pissed off all those
people I think Trump did say that he
said they're bringing drugs into our
country but it doesn't matter cuz the
media doesn't report on it and they clip
it all out anyway but I don't care about
the media anymore but that's what you do
is you find is is getting a like they're
struggling to reach six figure audiences
but back then it mattered oh no for sure
but today it's now it's just like let
the media not report it I don't care
anymore we we put out we put out one
clip on on this channel and it beats
CNN's entire Prime Time ratings in the
key demo cenan's getting like 40K they
are not influential with young people
anymore done way media has changed the
definition into what we're doing right
now is we are the media is like frogs in
a pot like I didn't realize I could
sense in 6 that it was happening and I
would say we are the media now just to
manifest it and make it happen sooner
but like to be in it for 15 years I
didn't it's hard to see the change but
we are it this is it it's actually
really really simple to understand how
these things happen we when when I'm
younger I'm looking at CNN Fox News ABC
and I'm looking at all these they're
getting millions of views I'm like wow
that's crazy and then me and all my
friends are hanging out doing our thing
that thing that we are doing is it when
we're older and these anchors have all
retired we didn't change what we did we
kept doing the same thing so you you
just inherit it because you're doing it
it wasn't that one day there was like a
switch was flicked no it's just younger
people even today right now with like
Tik Tok and other social media platforms
short form uh YouTube it's why YouTube
is rolling out shorts we like
Millennials watch shows like this
younger people are consuming shorter
Clips they're you know they investing in
influencers exactly thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast.net